cet amendement vise à élargir la portée
de la mission pédagogique attribuée à
l'art comme en matière de protection des
oeuvres et des objets auxquels sont
attachés sont attachés pardon un droit
d'auteur ou un droit voisin ou des
droits d'exploitation audiovisuelle
la loi telle que présentée une cible
aujourd'hui que les publics scolaires
pour que cet objectif soit adressée au
bon public et que la nouvelle autorité
remplissent avec efficacité son objectif
de sensibilisation à la diffusion de
l'offre légale il m'apparaît utile
détendent expressément cette mission aux
élèves de l'enseignement supérieur eu
égard à leur intense usage 30
professionnels que personnels des
contenus à protéger la création de l'art
comme qui pérennise une réponse graduée
salué pour son caractère pédagogique
offre l'occasion de gagner en efficacité
quant au ciblage des publics directement
concernés par le piratage
est un collègue monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement part du constat tout à fait
juste d'un manque de connaissance par
les étudiants des grands axes de
propriété intellectuelle cela est
d'autant plus vrai que les étudiants
actuels sont une génération confronté
très tôt à l'univers du numérique et qui
a dû en faire un usage massif dans les
conditions de la pandémie il s'agit donc
d'une extension tout à fait bienvenu
démission de l'as rome c'est un avis
favorable merci mme anna ministre
je suis bien sûr faveur sur le fond
à étendre des actions de sensibilisation
en direction des étudiants mais le texte
le permet déjà expressément puisque la
rédaction actuelle du projet de loi
n'est pas limitative tous les publics
sont visés bien entendu et chacun peut
se saisir de cette sensibilisation je
pense que le texte de l'amendement
proposé pourrait même avoir un effet
contre-productif en la matière puisqu'il
pourrait sembler réservés cette
sensibilisation aux états et aux seuls
élèves et étudiants je crois qu'on peut
on doit pouvoir a traversé à informer
les internautes adultes sur les risques
encourus en cas de téléchargements
illicites et les sensibiliser à
l'existence d'une offre légale je suis
donc défavorable à cet amendement non
pas sur le fond mais sur les effets
contre-productifs pourrait avoir si la
ministre monsieur bresson
je veux pas faire de peine à l'auteur de
l'amendement mais je peste déjà
suffisamment contre les injonctions qui
sont développées par notre assemblée sur
les programmes scolaires pour ne pas
souhaiter qu'en plus on fasse des
injonctions sur les programmes
universitaires et je rappelle que
l'autonomie des universités les conduit
quand même à définir eux-mêmes leurs
programmes et leurs enseignements donc
je suis vraiment désolé mais je ne
voterai pas cet amendement merci chers
collègues donc je mets au voile
amendement 8 avec un avis favorable de
la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement entier pour
quiconque
qui s'abstient ils ne paient adopté un
amendement 39 monsieur baky
c'est le président